foreign
and while we're on the subject of the
trumps
Donald Trump didn't interview this week
with Tucker Carlson the man who
in text messages revealed during the
Dominion lawsuit said he wished Trump
would go away he was looking forward to
never having to talk about him again
hates him with a passion
and then sat down like a little sad
puppy to interview Donald Trump and give
him a shoulder to cry on
but it wasn't Trump that was crying it
wasn't Tucker either because according
to Donald Trump's interview
it was actually the courthouse workers
in New York that were sobbing
uncontrollably when poor old Donald
Trump was brought in for the arraignment
here is what Donald Trump said to Tucker
they were incredible when I went to the
courthouse which is also a prison in a
sense
I'm sorry before I could even finish
that statement like what it's also kind
of like a print no it's actually not
like that's not what a courthouse is a
courthouse is a courthouse it's which
where you have trials it's where you
have arraignments it's where you
sometimes go to pay parking tickets it's
it's not the prison I'm sure they
probably have a holding cell there for
people that are held in contempt if
there's not a local County Jail nearby
but a courthouse is not in and of itself
also a prison so that's just a weird
statement and it's not even the dumbest
thing he said so I'll continue
they signed me in and I'll tell you
people were crying they were actually
crying he said
it's just sobbing just tears flowing
like a river throughout that Manhattan
Courthouse they had to put out wet floor
signs because the tears I guess were
just overwhelming
nobody was crying
if there was any crying taking place in
that courtroom that day it was most
likely tears of joy tears of joy that
Justice had finally caught up with
Donald Trump tears of joy that this man
was no longer to get away with
everything that he has been accused of
for years and years and years and years
tears of joy that maybe maybe
this guy might finally get his
comeuppance
but even then I don't even think they
were crying tears of joy they were just
people doing their jobs like it's just
our job but I will say if Donald Trump
thinks these workers in Manhattan love
him
there is video where Donald Trump was
you know they were kind of holding the
doors for people and then when it was
Trump's turn to walk through it they
just let it go and it almost hit him in
the face
so I I don't exactly think those workers
were in love with you
not to mention we're talking about a
courthouse in Manhattan
Donald Trump you are universally
disliked in Manhattan if this had been a
courtroom in Texas yeah you probably
would have had some some Die Hard Trump
supporters and they're crying for you
same thing if it was in Texas or Florida
or Alabama yeah I'd believe that story
then
but she has a point Donald like when
you're gonna lie to people and of course
Tucker Carlson didn't push back at all
because he's a coward but if you're
gonna lie to people you gotta make the
LIE believable Donald I mean come on
you've done this enough you know how to
play the game
nobody's gonna believe that these
Courthouse workers that other people
have seen were crying that day
there is nobody With Tears in their eyes
on video or in any of the pictures there
is no one coming out to corroborate your
story Tucker Carlson if he had a shred
of dignity would have pushed back on
this but of course he doesn't so he
didn't
but nobody in that Courthouse was sad
Donald except for you
and I say that because you've talked a
big game attacking that judge
before and after your arraignment but
you were silent during the arraignment
you said a total of about 10 words most
of them just one word at a time yes no
thank you not guilty
so when you actually had the opportunity
to stand up and tell that judge what you
thought you didn't do it because you're
also a coward so instead you then go
running to your little buddy Tucker
Carlson who again claims to hate you you
tell him a lie he doesn't push back
and nobody believed your story
it's April which means Earth month is
here this is the time to consider the
products you buy and the impact they
have on our planet so if you're still
using conventional toilet paper in your
home there's no better time to switch to
Reels 100 percent bamboo toilet paper 30
million trees are destroyed every year
for toilet paper in the U.S alone real
paper makes toilet paper from 100 bamboo
stocks which grow forever no cutting
down trees so when you use real it
doesn't feel like you're sacrificing
anything to help the Earth real paper is
soft and fluffy the way you're used to
it's always shipped free to my door in
plastic free packaging I can schedule it
on a subscription if I want and real is
partnered with one tree planted and with
every box of real paper you buy they
fund reforestation efforts across the
country make a positive change this
Earth month go to realpaper.com Pacman
use code Pacman for 30 percent off and
free shipping the link is down below